[Music]
Star Wars The Old Republic Knights of
the eternal throne the Trey trailer said
the starburst patron this one comes from
lo hit Banerjee I think I said your name
right for the first time ever one of our
top reward tiers whatever video you
requesting was put up on YouTube he
usually requests these short films that
are like trailers for video games a lot
of which I've never seen such as Star
Wars The Old Republic he said we don't
need any backstory on it I'm like are
you sure are you sure about that
SW fans get a little bit upset if you
miss anything I'm sure their folks we
should have read before haha
that's trailer your webseries let's see
let's see what flies over our heads
well you know it'll be like an x-wing or
something ah-ha-ha-ha-ha flying
[Music]
[Music]
she's doing it with a kid thanks man
[Laughter]
yeah this is a timeless romance
stop using the force yeah what did I
tell you about using the footprint
it's a Star Wars 300
there's a darkness with you
nice oh dude you're gonna care away
no she was trying to shield her powers
whoo-hoo [ __ ] man no give her tats and
then more tasks
[Applause]
yeah go save her
[Music]
nibbler
[Music]
how's she gonna get it some badass fight
in suit
[Applause]
[Music]
has she been indoctrinated though like
[Music]
comment below what are the yellow
lightsabers mean
[Music]
nice
Oh
okay well she has been indoctrinated now
she knows her mom to bands such like a
cool little subtle fight I know what's
happened to you
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna do to her they're gonna hurt
her into some kind of a powerful sieve
do we have to play the video game to
find out that's a practical use
I never thought this does look like a
ray huh yeah I know it's not
oh that her like grown-up Oh
[Music]
Oh Knights of the eternal throne I love
this cuz this game has three titles
[Laughter]
complicated income this really does make
me want to play Star Wars games and
stuff like this oh yeah this is also
like if they had a Star Wars movie that
had sequences that felt like these I
would be so amped like this is such a
such a beautiful short film yeah man
there's not a lot of dialogue in here no
it's primarily its visual storytelling
which is a majorly appropriate for the
Star Wars media and for a wholly
animated video yeah I know the people
making it or used to working hyper
visual you know and to have it be a
character piece that's like so
heartbreaking it's a heartbreaking
character piece that gets you invested
in the story I want to know how that's
gonna conclude I think the mom loses
that's my guess Matt if she does that's
our worst thing to have happen earth is
the best place to stay you don't want to
go outside of this galaxy no my question
though is has the mom just kind of
stayed a similar age this whole time
like is the little girl age very quickly
yeah yeah she's like Robin Williams and
Jack yeah oh your your mom looks about
the same and you're like full-grown well
that's cool because you got a
juxtaposition of two different types of
warriors like the moms raising her this
whole time to be a warrior and kind of
like no hydropower Zidane I think it's
gonna like take advantage of you and
then she exposes it that it leads on
this pad out of mulch arrestor but then
she's also the villain it's such a cool
like internal battle that also reflects
on the external side of things I love
that it's so neat yeah and and even the
emotional stuff was kind of potent
because like at the beginning when her
mom like catches her levitating the toy
and then like forces it into it and I
was like that's kind of messed up and
then you see why later you know that she
maybe did that and so you get kind of
the motivation of the kid feeling like
oh you're trying to limit leave me and
these people aren't you know like yes
core memory like that you know like oh
yeah
nuance to such like a six-minute story
without it's crazy exposition I even
love that one fight that they had it's
choreographed in a cool way but it's not
like hyper stylized it feels very
realistic and it's one take and it's not
like let's blast a big Star Wars music
over this like really subtle fight to
try to make it seem cooler than it is
but as if you take away like I'm all
that music it actually feels cooler
because it feels like a really grounded
in reality fight sequence it feels like
this stylistic elements that make it
Star Wars those earmarks you know it's
like they know when to put them to the
side and just let the action be gripping
it's like I feel like it used all of its
aesthetic elements really well and also
too like I've said this a million times
one of my favorite things about anything
Star Wars is just the world and the
designs and stuff all the different like
guards and stuff they have a really cool
like I don't know I was really dazzled
by this it makes me wish that because I
know they do like the animated shows
that a lot of Star Wars fans are huge
like fans of I would love if they would
do an animated movie along the lines of
this
but these kinda graphics its maxima kiss
in there look at this whole thing yeah
like I haven't watched many of the
animated shows it's video games so
there's already kind of a thing that
you're used to but when it is more
photo-real I am a bit more engaged than
when the animation is a bit more
caricature or cartoon like especially of
characters that we've seen in
live-action yeah or whatever I really
did love this a hell of a lot my one
issue with it is what's with people
trying to make woman front and center
now a Dave's man force sensitive girl
having to learn a control repel I am so
sick of this feminine [ __ ] being thrown
at my face I mean it's so good at using
the dark side I mean if this was men it
would be a whole different story I love
it I love it and I wouldn't notice it it
would make sense to me because I too am
a man yeah it's common and it's normal
but we needs women oh you're trying to
push the agenda a little too much people
how can I relate to a woman I just don't
I don't get it
I don't get it I've never been a woman I
never liked my mom or sister I killed
them both a battery
relationship of both those people yeah
they're dead now oh man
yeah because I couldn't relate and they
couldn't do man things without it being
strike him out it was up to them to
figure it out all right you were doing
your thing glad they got it down anyway
maybe I'll just keep watching their
short films a bit but happen
I'm cuz they're just as rewarding yeah
before we wrap this up low hit Bannerjee
my friend you are consistently great at
recommending these man he knows how to
pick the coolest video game short films
to present to us man he's constantly
telling me how he's inspired by the
short films that he recommends us and
he's a writer himself a filmmaker
himself go check out his YouTube channel
here it is flashing on the screen and I
got to tell you guys this guy's a very
talented dude you gotta keep a lookout
for because in the future with a guy
that this level of passion he's gonna
make something of himself why cuz he's a
man oh definitely not this feminist
stuff yeah that doesn't involve or
include men in any way shape or form
yeah if you read it if it was a woman
would not be saying any of this because
I'd be like you're pushing your own
agenda now yeah I would be like why are
you trying to ruin everything I love by
you know making me think about rights
and empathy and [ __ ] you know I hope the
woman who got to this place that's just
an interesting you know it's like of
course a woman would think were being
serious
Luther sensitivity that men don't have
you know be cool oh he if you could
program a film I'm not even kidding if
you could program some kind get your
mates together and just you have a film
festival of these little shorts that
could actually be really cool make that
happen in your living room or a theater
revival house near you subscribe for the
real rejects click that notification Val
you know how it goes chicken stop
patreon weekly Q&A is TV show reaction
watch alongs music video coverage and
more of a loved
have John actually pledged to the
patreon today